in this video and show you a slightly
more complex example where the slope of
the function can be different at
different points in the function the
slots of an example here I plot to the
function f of a equals a squared let's
again look at the point a equals two so
a square is what f of a is equal to four
let's nut a slightly to the right so now
a is equal to two point zero zero one f
of a which is a squared it's going to be
approximately four point zero zero four
it turns out that the exact value your
partner calculating figure this out it's
actually four point zero zero four zero
zero one but I'm just to say 4.04 is
close enough so what this means is that
when a is equal to two let's draw this
on the plot so what we're saying is that
if a is equal to 2 then F of a is equal
to four and here at the um x and y axes
are not drawn to scale technically this
vertical height should be much higher
than this horizontal height so the x and
y axes are not on the same scale um but
if I now nudge a to two point zero 1
then F of a becomes roughly four point
zero four so if you draw this little
triangle again what this means is that
if I know eight to the right by 0.01 F
of a goes up four times as much by 0.04
so in the language of calculus we say
that the slope that is the derivative of
f of a at a equals two is four or to
write this out without calculus notation
we say that Dda
of f of a is equal to four when a is
equal to two now one thing about this
function f of a equals a squared is that
the slope is different for different
values of a this is different than the
example we saw on the previous slide so
let's look at a different point if a is
equal to five
since F equals two in half equals five
then a squared is equal to 25 so that's
F of a if I know eight to the right
again just tiny little notch to 8 so now
a is five point zero 1 then F of a will
be approximately
the twenty five point zero one zero so
what we see is that by nudging a up by
point over one f of a goes out ten times
as much so we have that D da f of a is
equal to ten when a is equal to five
because F of a goes out ten times as
much as a does when I make a tiny little
nudge to a so one way to see why the
derivative is different at different
points is that if you draw that need a
little triangle right at different
locations on this you see that the ratio
of the height of the triangle over the
width of the triangle is very different
at different points on the curve so here
the slope is equal to more when a is
equal to two but is equal to ten when a
is equal to five now if you pull up a
calculus textbook in calculus textbook
will tell you that DD a of F of a so f
of a is equal to a square so that's D da
of a squared one of the formulas you
find that a calculus textbook is that
this thing the slope of the function a
squared is equal to 2a not going to
prove this but the way you find this out
is that you open up a calculus textbook
to the table formulas and they'll tell
you the derivative of two of a squared
is equal to 2a and indeed this is
consistent with what we've worked out
namely when a is equal to 2 the slope
the function to a is 2 times 2 is
therefore equal to 4 and when a is equal
to 5 then the slope of the function two
times a is 2 times 5 is equal to 10 so
if you ever proper calculus textbook and
you see this formula that the derivative
of a squared is equal to 2a all that
means is that for any given value of a
if you nudge it up with by 0.0001
already your tiny little value you would
expect F of a to go up by 2a that is the
slope or the derivative times however
much you had nice to the right the value
of a now one tiny little detail you know
I had used these approximate symbols
here and this wasn't exactly 4.04
there's an extra 0.001 hanging out there
it turns out that this extra 0.01 does
low thing here is because we were
nudging a to the right by 0.001 it were
instead not yet to the right by this you
know info testimony small value then
this extra ever term will go away and
you find that the amount that F of a
goes up is exactly equal to the
derivative times the amounts that unite
a to the right and the reason why is not
4.04 exactly is because derivatives are
defined using these infinitely small not
just to a rather than you know 0.001
which is a while and while 0.001 is
small is not infinitely small so that's
why the amounts that F of a went up
isn't exactly given by the formula but
is only kind of approximately given by
the derivative to wrap up this video
let's just go through a few more quick
examples the example you've already seen
is that if F of a equals a squared then
a calculus textbooks
formula table and will tell you that the
derivative is equal to 2a and so the
example we went through was that if n is
equal to 2 F of a equals 4 and then we
nudge a so it's a little bit bigger then
F of a is about 4.04 and so f of a went
up four times as much and indeed when a
is equal to two the derivative is equal
let's look at some other examples let's
say instead 2 f of a is equal to 8 Q if
you go to a calculus textbook and look
up the table of formulas you see that
the slope of this function again the
derivative of this function is equal to
3a squared so you can you know get this
formula out of a calculus textbook so
what this means so the way to interpret
this is as follows let's take n equals 2
as an example again so f of a or 8 cubed
is equal to 8 does 2 to the power 3 so
if we give a a tiny little lunch
you find that f of a is about eight
point zero one two and feel free to
check this take two point zero zero one
to the power
me you find that it's very close to
eight point zero one two and indeed when
a is equal to 2 that's 3 times 2 squared
that's equal to 3 times 4 is equal to 12
so the derivative formula predicts that
if you nudge 8 to the right by time a
little bit F of a should go up 12 12
times as much and indeed this is true
when a went up by 0.001 F of a went up
12 times as much by 0.01 to just one
last example and it will wrap up let's
say the F of a is equal to the log
function right so I'm gonna write log of
a and I'm gonna use this as the base a
logarithm so some people write that as
log log of a so if you go to a calculus
textbook you'll find that when you take
the derivative of log of a so this is a
function that it just looks like that
the slope of this function is given by 1
over a so the way to interpret this is
that if a is any value again let's just
keep using equals 2 as an example and
you nudge a to the right by 0.001 you
would expect F of a to go up by 1 over a
that despite the derivative times the
amounts that you increase a so in fact
if you plop a calculator you find that
if a is equal to 2 F of a is about
0.6931 5 and if you increase F and if
you increase a to 2.0 1 then F of a is
about 0.693 6 5 so it's gone up by 0.005
and indeed if you look at the formula
for the derivative when a is equal to 2d
da f of a is equal to 1/2 so this
derivative formula predicts that if you
bump up a by 0.001 you would expect F of
a to go up by only one half as much and
one half 0.001 is 0.005
which is exactly what we got right that
when a goes up by 0.001 going from
equals to 2 equals 2.0 1 FFA goes up by
half as much since I've grown up by
approximately 0.05 Civic gardens or
triangle if you will is that if on the
horizontal axis this goes up by 0.001 on
the vertical axis log of a goes up by
half of that at some point
0:05 and so that 1 over a 1/2 in this
case when a is equal to 2 that's just
the slope of this line when a is equal
to 2 so that's it for derivatives there
just to take home messages from this
video first is that the derivative of a
function just means the slope of a
function and the slope of a function can
be different at different points on the
function in our first example where F of
a equals 3 a there was a straight line
the derivative was the same everywhere
it was 3 everywhere but for other
functions like F of a equals a squared
or f of e equals log of a the slope of
the line theories and so the slope or
the derivative can be different at
different points on the curve so that's
a first take away derivative just means
slope of a line second takeaway is that
if you want to look up the derivative of
the function you can flip open your
calculus textbook or look at Wikipedia
and often get a formula for the slope of
these functions at different points so
that I hope you have an intuitive
understanding of derivatives or of
slopes of lines let's go into the next
video we'll start to talk about the
computation drop and how to use that to
compute derivatives of more complex
functions